une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux sans filtre des podcasts on parle de
ce qu'on veut avec nos invités d'un site
web tv l'état job je suis ph quand même
si bart que bienvenu sans fil gang
cette semaine le podcast est présenté
par là haut comme butcher là où comme au
chaud c'est en toute honnêteté que j'ai
goûté à beaucoup comme ça c'est mon
combo de jeu préféré on a rencontré les
deux en fait les trois fondateurs de la
aucun doute chez moi de ma copine sont
vraiment des jeunes entrepreneurs
québécois qui font un produit de qualité
besoin on peut pas en prendre
ah c'est là où kampuchea ils font une
collaboration avec camélia synesis ouais
c'est ça synopsis en fait c'est une
maison tu es à montréal j'allais acheter
un cadeau justement pour mon beau frère
là bas pour trouver les meilleurs thés
afin de faire des culbutes show inspiré
par lors du thé donc s'ils partent des
saveurs de thé pour ensuite créer les
kambou de choses qui font que ça vient
vraiment cherché un goût unique là je
vous en parle je suis passionné par ce
que c'est vraiment les meilleurs comme
lucho que j'ai goûté ils font tirer 12
combustion donc une caisse de 12 si vous
allez leur écrire podcast un message
privé soit sur instagram ou sur facebook
on les remercie beaucoup de collaborer
avec nous pour le pad kaspi j'adore les
encourager sont vraiment ce match c'est
des produits excellents
j'ai sûrement pas du tout pays points
mais je pense qu'ils aient voté en masse
pour que vous compreniez que c'est une
compagnie qu'on aime qu'on remercie
grandement cette semaine des jeux pas de
casse vient tout juste de dire que
quelqu'un d'autre à château beau frère
avant dès maintenant aux autres dans le
fond et dans notre famille est avec tout
le monde est tellement occupé on a fait
des noëls cette descente au parfum homme
effectifs y est déjà donné son cadeau
une tasse de camellia sinensis puis avec
une boîte de thé
variété de sites c'est seulement dans
leurs suppôts marilou qu'on connaît pour
surtout pour trois fois par jour qui a
commencé en étant un blog de cuisine sur
les réseaux sociaux qui devenus des
livres des revues des et tout plein de 3
8 % québécois le bébé de marie lou qui
avant était chanteuse pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent moi je m'en souviens moi si
les plus jeunes peut-être ont manqué
cette période mais on est revenu on peut
aussi sur cette période de sa vie avec
ses hauts et ses bas et le succès
phénoménal on s'entendra par jour qui
rapidement devenu un incontournable
marilou que eu un impact sur la manière
dont les gens voient perçoit et
consomment et cuisine avec la nourriture
n'est pas considérable quand même je
pense que tout le monde et des jeux soit
tournée déjà mangé une recette de
marilou je pense tout le monde peut-être
pas mais on est tout à fait beaucoup de
monde
le relève et dans beaucoup de foyers
québécois c'est vraiment un grandiose
alors on compare le succès là et on
parle de sa nouvelle occupation
principale qui est celle d'être maman
un look et déjà deux petites filles ont
aussi parlé de les réseaux sociaux pour
contre pourquoi croyez vous serez poule
noire
alors évidemment c'est parce que mes
belles personnes avec des belles valeurs
avec et qui est drôle qui est qui qui
est sympathique qui est énergique encore
une fois que l'air bien qui a l'air bien
c'est le plus important
pas très bien alors rêve scemama de
rekem
merci d'être là et la trilogie
ben en fait écouter les signaux des
commentaires les sinon l'état mme diop
laissez nous laisser nous tout ce que
vous pouvez nous laisser pour nous aider
à saper son bout de chemin depuis on
aime ça est avec vous en cette veille du
nouvel an et en restent pas longtemps
puis on a aimé cette année là avec vous
mais on va reparler de façon dans notre
rétrospective de la qui sent bien mais
pour l'instant bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
non j'aime les divertissements mais mon
mode de vie comme plate parce que
j'écoute je quitte au courant de rien je
ne fais pas de films tchèques pas de
serre estime bord des mêmes arrêté les
enfants c'est comme les enfants qui
n'ont à la base non moi j'ai à chaque
fois j'ai deux minutes je vois créé et
joué à écrire quelque chose je veux
cuisiner je vois avec les gens que tu la
vis pas s'auto j'ai l'impression que
c'est juste complètement déconnectés de
la vie avec elle pendant les derniers
mois que te demande pas les daudet tout
était quand même à fait d'accord autant
plaisir cuisiner ça jamais arrêté et oui
et non il ya eu des passagers trek et
rentable ouais ce qui m'écoeure la
cuisine c'est la vaisselle au début je
faisais des 10 12 recettes par jour
petit la vaisselle qui s'accumulent
gepan ans comme six mois un an presque
j'avais le goût de vous mais reste à
cause de la tâche de la vie de torche et
des gt gt plus capable sa danse à lille
au delà de 12 par jour c'est non
nécessaires pendant longtemps j'ai fait
ça quand j'étais toute seule avec alex
au début le fait qu il ya eu une période
où est ce que je suis fait une petite et
47 mais pas de la cuisine papa de peu de
manger aux postes créés mais vraiment de
tout ce qui vient j'aurais pas été un
bon investissement de t'acheter une
plonge plomb chez vous une planche et
ouais comme des restos haute et d'un
gros reste aujourd'hui fait juste mettre
des affaires dans un rack comme ça tu
fermes sur sa lave du louvre
l'exode au début toutes les recettes
qu'on voyait c'était toi qui l'avais
fait
oui je suis loin je peux tu peux bouger
je peux bouger
ouais ouais enfin sauté plus besoin d'un
foyer rien qui court montage les gens
sont avec nous mais oui tout au début
c'était moi puis alex en faisait tout où
on était trop en fait on avait une
adjointe puis à l'exploit fait qu' on
est parti et ses fous pareils cas qu'on
avait on au mr on marche et alexis il
est des semaines d or d or d en faire
des copies cac prend des photos de
coupes et puis dieu tu parles eddie bo
est ce que ça rend fou un poussines ont
littéralement jour et nuit lance
couchais tard on se levait tout on
faisait juge ce c'était limite maladif
notes afin comme quand la passion croix
de la folie un peu puis
évidemment mais en même temps tout a
grossi tellement vide
on dirait que ces lointains même temps
c'est possible on tentera par jour va
voir
huit buts à ses fous - fait que tu aies
on est quand même rendu avec pas mal
d'employés mais c'est surtout le fait
qu' on est parti d alex et moi on a un
enfant on se marie on se dit c'est
quelque chose peu après c'est de tout
faire se pique ça continue moi c'est ce
qui me rend la vie via indiqué que moi
on est pas mal d'embûches six autres
accepté venir là parce qu'ils ont fini
la décennie 2010 dans le fond puis trois
fois par jour c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une success story de cette
décennie les foules mayon beaucoup de
monde se connaisse pas trois fois par
jour au québec
ouais beaucoup de monde qui ont pas il
ya beaucoup de monde qui l'ont pas mais
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui ont
un des livres qui ont un des magazines
ces fous pareils plus et on termine on
termine décennies pis il ya beaucoup de
noms surtout en fait en cuisine c'est de
loin le nom que la plus grande
croissance dans les dix dernières années
écoute c'est tellement pas quelque chose
à quoi je pense c'est des fois et des
fois je veux réaliser comme parce que je
veux travailler sur un truc on va me
parler des chiffres de vente oui c'était
un demi million de livres vendus si
énorme beaucoup de lui mais quand tito
au quotidien ou d'études et c'est pas
quelque chose que tu tu peux pas
t'arrêter a sauté parce que demain matin
tout peu tard et tout peut arrêter mais
si une chose que j'aurais pas pu prédire
si c'est trop beau par jour dans ma
ville plein temps en temps je suis parti
à 11 ans j'ai commencé à faire des
plateaux en musée et d'aider des albums
des défis niveau et dino quilico puis
garufi on n'y en ait pas l'affecter
c'est un beau cadeau un beau défi dans
ma vie trois par jour c'est incroyable
je pense on est sensiblement le même
dans le même temps je me dis tu as quel
âge j'ai 28 ans exactement
puis à un si jeune âge genèse de u2
grande carrière dans deux choses
complètement différentes c'est quand
même fou qui le fou j'ai commencé à
travailler jeunes aussi quand j'ai parti
trop beau par jour j'étais quand même
une gêne que j'avais déjà comment de
bagage professionnel ça fait de moi une
personne c'est peut-être pour ça que je
pilote puis j'ai dans le fond je me sens
comme si j'ai quarante l'été parce que
j'ai un bagage professionnel est un peu
lourd mais non long way on s'est vus
ouais puis en même temps et mais c'est
seulement ce qui fait de moi une
personne qui a toujours besoin d'être
occupé aussi parce que j'ai jamais eu et
je parle à l'école d'une manière stand
or il n'y avait pas de temps mort dans
ma vie si je t'ai tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps qui fait que c'est
peut-être ça aussi que tu fais en sorte
que je tout le temps en train de me
ramasser dans les projets pendant les
nouveaux défis parce que j'ai besoin de
ça bouge us que ses seins je suis
inquiet oui mais mais ouais c'est que ça
fait longtemps qu'ils aient que j'arrête
pas dans le fond puis les enfants ça n'a
pas changé
cette grève le stade peut atténuer oui
vraiment vraiment je pense sincèrement
je pense que j'ai fait une dépression
après ma première je peux bien sûr parce
que je t'ai pas et j'étais pas bien plus
d'énergie
non je me sentais pas mais j'avais peur
de tout j'avais je suis devenu un peu et
je m'isolais beaucoup aux cimes été
entendu une séparation effet beaucoup à
10 ans 4 s'accumulent tout vis aux usa
j'ai l'impression qu'ils étaient sama
j'étais une personne libre et et j'étais
tout en train de choisir mon horaire
dont mais quand je voulais être affectés
salle amènent les enfants dans une ville
certaines structures de paul choix d'
des suites des fous je fais peut-être la
nuit votre club vous y fait que c'est un
fait et des responsabilités qui m'ont
comme vraiment à ça me fait que ça le
change est cependant à bout mais je sens
depuis les derniers mois que je retombe
soumis pâte et il faut dire que ma
deuxième grossesse tu es vraiment
vraiment vraiment une surprise si
j'ai vraiment pas prévu c'est arrivé
tellement vite fait que oui ça les
change évidemment pas une chose dans ma
vie le sam et mais mon désir que les
choses bougent on non pas le deuxième
est le cas la belle rama plus via va
avoir 80 semaine prochaine puis la plus
jeune à l'heure n'a et quelques quelques
mois affectée jésus rapprocher
l'approché puis et à travers tout ça
quand même à l'aide du public la sas
ajoute m mais l'odeur huawei 600 g 5
depuis une couple de mois je suis moins
l'adage je trouve qu'elle est les sites
de potins me reprenne vraiment moins fun
puis je sais j'ai mise en forme et et
est une chose que je suis vraiment
chanceux ici que ce soit tellement bien
passé malgré les circonstances qui on
s'entend que quand tu rachètes les
portes d'une compagnie at on expliqué
pape quitte pas la garde des enfants
puis de de soupe salle aurait pu être
une 4e rapprochement monumental puis ça
s'est tellement bien passé que j'ai j'ai
quasiment pas d'en parler parce que j'ai
pas tellement 10 mai six lots chaleur
afin tellement que c'est comme trop
parfait mais c'est pas que c'est parfait
c'est juste qu'il ya tellement de
respect entre alex et moi puis est
tellement désir de mettre nos enfants au
centre puis en fait que c'est tellement
elle qui de la plus haute importance que
on arrive à enlever nos bouts de deggo
désagréable il y à vraiment s'entendre
sur tout puis je veux pas trop en parler
parce que c'est c'est la présence à
lagos le monde pour autant que ça peut
pas bien à les noms sont logés entre le
temps on a tellement agacé le monde
parce qu'on avait rare du petit couple
parfait et qu'ensuite on sait devoir
c'est le moment aussi bien la réponse
est diane roy était pas parfait audio
ont divorcé puis le divorce va super
bien fait que c'est comme les gens ils
ça les rend malheureuse il faut que j'en
parle pas trop le j'en parle parce qu on
est entre nous mais j'en parle pas trop
parce que je peux fourrage ou
partiellement
c'est madame eu pour vous la médina oui
c'est parfait pour ouvrir sa pâte
d'amande c'est merveilleux wesh écoutes
chouette à jette pas tout le monde de
ses forces et là c'est pas vraiment la
meilleure chose si ça arrive aux mamans
le way c'est tout et dans le respect de
l'enfant
quand tu passes par l'enfant de pas le
choix de d'être maître toit de côté
petits besoins petites blessures le fait
que j'aime en perspective sûrement avoir
un bon enfant j'ai testé guillon gbagbo
depuis que j'ai eu un enfant ma
perspective sur toute la l'échelle
d'importance des choses que j'accordais
dans ma vie était chambouler
complètement
oui vraiment ces méthodes peu j'imagine
que c'est un un brain de bouffe prend
une autre tournure quand un enfant c'est
un autre signification tant doit
tellement petits arrivent des trucs
d'efforts bureau il dit annick des
petites urgences pige comme si de rien
mais grave at-on hypo en danger il n'y a
pas de ça oui ça mais ça l'est depuis il
ya aussi une chose c'est que pour ma
part j'ai toujours en fait il ya
maintenant les gens que j'admire le plus
le sipo les personnes qui arrivent à se
bâtir des empires matériel et c'est les
femmes à la maison il papa à la maison
j'ai tellement d'admiration pour ces
gens là parce que honnêtement c'est la
chose dans une vie qui nécessitent le
plus de développer des qualités humaines
s'il n'y a pas de ya pas de cachettes
paul choix travis pas patience et à tout
tout tout petit bébé dauphin se meurt
mais oui tu es tellement tu paies choix
dans les quatre heures et cordes la nuit
puissent pas dormir
c'est la pire version c'est là vers soi
même puis d'autres que moi j'ai
tellement d'admiration pour les gens qui
se disent est dédié à ce point et il met
à cette phase est là de leur vie et qui
vraiment mettre tout leur temps dans
l'éducation des enfants pendant la la la
maison le bras vous ouvrez moi je serais
pas capable d aller travailler comme un
congé pour moi ah ouais ouais ouais
vraiment
ça me c'est comme mon titre en touche
dès que j'ai pas de divertissement mais
je pense que mon divertissement c'est
vraiment ma job c'est là que je vois
aujourd'hui ouais je vais aller comme
respirer me vider la tête créer du rire
pour ce genre venir à la maison c'est là
que la job à commence selon fut bon
parce que pour moi une job c'est cécile
à plat jobs la plus importante est
vraiment humainement tout qu'est ce que
tu fais ta vie puis c'est avec mes
filles que je me développe le plus pied
avec mon job surtout pas vraiment par
les enfants mais le couple cas qu'il ya
des enfants n'ont que des parts non plus
pour rester un couple ouais ça c'est
très très très difficile démenti cette
méthode est très conscient qu'il faut
nourrir seul belge ans oui j'en suis
consciente et ce que je les fais
parfaitement
sûrement pas mais est-ce qu'on a des
bonnes intentions et je pense qu'elle a
raison pour laquelle justement je pense
qu'ils montrent jamais moi on fait
vraiment un bon duo puis on est au
rebond
une bonne équipe c'est que nos forces et
nos faiblesses se complique vraiment le
fait que je compte en fait je suis
tellement chanceuse bâton mais parce que
tg2 mes enfants ont deux pas perdre
c'est tellement post
honnêtement si vous m'aviez ya cinq ans
le je me serais pas non mais j'ai
réellement été déçu de moi tellement été
déçu parce que c'est pas l'image
parfaite que je m'étais fait et je vis
tellement la perfection dans la vie puis
je vis tellement je veux tellement que
tout soit bien pigé aurait vraiment fait
je ré capoter mais l'homme jeu médical
mais ta famille prend la plus parfaite
qu'elle aurait été si tu avais toufik
quelque chose qui pour la perfection qui
était qui et qui pourrait en dessous non
mais non mais c'est opter deux personnes
puis je pense que alex et moi un peu
mythomane et maritimes hautes chaumes
s'appelle alex pecci vraiment compliqué
à chaque jeudi alex personne me dit
quelque chose
très à l'aise
mais dans le fond c'est qu'il ya des
gens avec qui c'est pas c'est juste que
déjà mais qui ne peut pas être en coupe
c'est un ami ou c'est un importe nos
instincts alex champagne ça reste mon
complice dans ma vie ça reste un impôt
retenu pour toujours mais c'était juste
qu'on n'était pas fait pour être mariés
ensemble mais j'ai quand même cette
chance l'été y ait des gens qui leur
relation se désagrège mais nous pose pas
vaincu adam est dans une compagnie comme
ça avec ton partenaire de vie c'est le
vit aujourd'hui c'est normal c'est quand
même complexe à motifs savons non ça va
c'est bien mais il ya eu lieu des buttes
ou est-ce que ça allait pas bien où est
ce que le hac et là on est on est en
train tout le vécu aussi bonne en goutte
c'est ok là on est en train de ramener
littéralement du travail à maison puis
les frontières sont vraiment floue entre
qu'est-ce qui est la relation de travail
qu'est ce qui la relation amoureuse
comme un dévot lui dans tout seul
comment tu te perds peu dans tout ça
c'est vraiment complexe d'ici pour
reprendre l'exemple que alexander et
quand ils viennent ici de dire qu'ils
ont passé 60 heures à prendre des photos
de copier quand tu passe son temps dans
une semaine à juste faire subi un
ajustement est les rechercher la
perfection comme tu parlais de qualité
s'ils ont su un peu l'image de trois
fois par jour on voit que c'est un peu
sutil halal espèce d'image parfaite
qu'on woippy ce sapin pas tout seul
c'est sûr qu'il ya un million d'embûches
reliés au travail bio qu'ils n'ont
aucune chance que ça traverse pour
écoute si nous en fait le plus gros
problème on se sait que nous ya jamais
eu un avant trois fois par jour ont
rencontré par jour fait c'est comme si
on n'a même pas pris le temps
d'investiguer par rapport à notre
relation de couple et chacun c'est
différent mais moi personnellement au
delà de ce même travail que nous sommes
actuellement concentrés sur epte sait on
en rit parce qu on pourrait juste pas là
c'est parfait parce qu'on a nos projets
on s'épanouit
on se retrouve à la maison soit on est
tellement contents de s'emparer de ce
lancement est à caserne g
genre de savoir qui est fait aujourd'hui
état les idées qui et comment ça s'est
passé comment ses collègues ouvrons
pilule la même chose pour moi de voir
comment mes projets avancent vite
il ya quelque chose je trouve des saints
dans le fait des merveilles
mais je pense que j'imagine j'ose croire
qui doit exister une façon de faire qui
en ayant tablé nice tu peux quand même
hâte et avec ta blonde
il ya une façon de mettre des limites
qui font que vous pouvez quand même vous
retrouver le soir tu mais je pense que
c'est ce que nous on n'a pas fait qui
aurait fallu qu'on fasse on it on a
attendu trop longtemps mais ça doit se
faire c'est parce que nous nous craquons
comportera la journée difficile de les
mettre complètement sur pause le soir le
sait ça reste un peu l'appareil kitty
vous sembliez à être deux
il travaille en tant pis on est de 7,2 à
tant d un temps vraiment deux intenses
et puis c'est sa vie c'est aussi que ça
prend quelque chose qu'un con mais la
job sur pause ou quiconque a conduit on
parle d'autre chose
fou qui reste quelque chose a parlé ici
mais qu'est-ce que je pense qu est ce
qui est le plus difficile c'est que dans
nos jobs c'est tellement il ya tellement
de stimulation dans nos jobs c'est
tellement stimulant sa digue dans une
drôle de parler d'hommes puis c'est que
quand paraît de parler de ça peut être
plate va peut être vraiment placer des
je pense que ça aussi c'est un défi
quand une business avec tonton conjointe
est de rendre la vie normale ou le
quotidien pop l'athlé défi pour les
rentes et ouais c'est clair parce que
mettons l'entrepreneuriat quand même
nouveau dans ma vie mais c'est c'est
vraiment pas en reste comme un jeu
j'aurai je voudrais jeu comme dans un
jeu le whisky à qui le comprend nouvelle
affaire met de l'avant c'est tellement
tu le dis c'est tellement stimulant qui
a apprécié le d'études est vrai que des
tout départ un peu ça exact c'est celle
des filles vraiment elle défie pis je
sais pas j'étais a pas de formule
magique mais même
à thé en moto qu'on enlève l'équation
que j'étais avec mon job dans ma
business
même moi c'est de me dire que d'aller
jouer tu es comme je peux et colorié ida
48 pilotes ma journée va finir moi je
souvent changé les enfants voire trois
heures c'est bien dit que de trois
heures à 8 heures il faut que je trouve
ça le fun est assise à faire des blocs
pied à jouer à quatre pattes c'est hyper
difficile de pas prendre mon téléphone
ou de pas mais en même temps c'est
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus important que
de développer mon lien avec mes enfants
rien mais cessons que ses plus plates
pour mon et groupe cb plus et même plus
le fun d'aller faire des trucs avec des
adultes pirée et puis travailler dans un
set efficace et c'est vraiment c'est ça
c'est d'essayer de garder un semblant de
sorte qu'au mans je trouve un grand défi
lé wifi tutoie tout est une femme
d'affaires peut-être de maman puis c'est
plus valorisé d'être fait avec une
grande carrière et d'une femme au foyer
temps tout dicté témoin moi j'ai une
mère à la maison on était quatre enfants
puis c'est la chose pour laquelle j'ai
le plus de gratitude dans ma vie d'avoir
eu cette merlotti nous donner tout son
temps qui nous a tout le temps tu es là
pour nous qu'ils ont élevé des belles
valeurs qui étaient eux qui étaient
présentes qui était qui a été dotée
quelques sous de la famille ensemble
mais mais c'est sûr mais être à l'avant
être avoir une grande carrière ses 50
dans la société bravo exactement ça me
fait complètement capoté
ces nouveaux quand même ce que comme
valorisation je pense qu'elle monde en
général
puis je vous aime et je m'inclus on aime
c'est flashy nos affaires d'une façon
sophistiquée t on mais tout qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur internet
c'est une forme de narcissisme qu'on a
toutes un peu mais je pense aussi que
c'est qu'à une certaine époque les
femmes à la maison c'était pas part
choix c'était parce que c'était comme ça
oui c'est dans le temps de nos grands
parents je veux dire la plupart étaient
à la maison le plus parti travailler pas
vraiment pis c'était l'homme qui qui qui
travaillait au besoin c'était comme ça
pif dans le fond le plus important c'est
que la femme puisse avoir le choix de
faire ce qu'elle veut mais il n'ya pas
décemment meilleur choix qu'un autre non
non non vraiment pas c'est juste que
c'est plus valorisées j'ai l'impression
de m'être partir une business ou de
réussir monétairement ou d'avoir quatre
chalets qui font que d'état la maison
dans la simplicité à crier halte ont
enfanté et en même temps il ya de plus
en plus sur les réseaux sociaux des
comptes de mer qui qui qui quittent et
qui enjolivent ou qui mettent en scène
leur quotidien aussi affecté j'ai
l'impression que tout est entré un peu
d'échangés ma blonde à écouter l'autre
fois vidéos youtube qui je sais comme
youtube qui colle à l'image sur
instagram de qui faisait décoller avec
leurs enfants sans le consentement de
leurs enfants souhaitant un bébé plaît
fais une collab avec une compagnie de
l'ange bleu tel bb king maker quand
linge pour actuelle pour bébé puis
finalement de ccc largeur savoir la mère
acquiesce way baisse à la base avoir un
enfant toutes les décisions dépend pour
lui ouais tant que j'avoue que l'eau
c'est quand même un peu capitaliser sur
un autre être humain je suis je fais
tellement c'est drôle j'en pars avec mon
ami la semaine passée pitt est aussi de
moi je montre paul visage d'une france
où les réseaux sociaux puis c'est juste
que je trouve germes à l'aise avec le
fait de pointer du doigt parce que moi
je fais des trucs pour eux font aucun
sens mais cessons kg j'ai vraiment
profondément un malaise avec les gens
qui utilisent leurs enfants pour aller
chercher des sous ou du riz ou de la
reconnaissance puis en même temps il ya
des choses comme je dis que je dois
faire qui rend les gens mais on est tous
transit dans notre processus à mes
moutons moelleux j'arrive à
à 18 ans puis un inventaire des passes
et sur la peur que mes parents ont mis
je sais pas comment je me sentirai ouais
parce que le style moi mettons g chez
nous j'ai des des cartables de photos
quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais mieux
sont à moins de personnes âgées mais
parce que c'est quand ça arrête
maintenant maintenant l'otan bébé et six
mois le titre prend des photos avec mes
temps proche quelqu'un c'est jusqu'à
temps que lui dise non
pitch devin qui a tellement dans sa vie
jamais ça vous mettons au restaurant de
choses à un parent qui fait qu'ils
placent son enfant piqué à 80 ans il
prend en photo sur les réseaux sociaux
presti critique je l'aimais se sait se
sait toutes les photos sur les réseaux
sociaux et pour tout une grande majorité
âgés c'est pas parce que tu es moi
j'assume vraiment qu'à 17 up de décoder
en faire moi je fais ça en écoutant du
guignol avec un parti de moi c'est mon
moment relaxe j'écoute pas de film puis
je fais ça j'ai la simca ce stade j mais
je devais pas en guerre les personnes
âgées pas tes jeux je l'assumé
pleinement mon c'est écrit dans mon fils
que je trouve beau puis j'aime le globe
tout seul c'est ce que je mets là mais
bien évidemment que j'ai des bobettes
fluo qui traînent des fois dans ma
cuisine pas j'ai deux enfants je le
prends juste pas en photo et j'ai
vraiment c'est ça je trouve ça fou
pareil quand qu'on s'engueule pour
stage'' quelque chose pour nous et un
heureux des hommes et ces femmes à temps
mais moi c'est une des photos que jesse
quel genre de cinq ans d'après la belle
photo par ta bouche carmin simple c'est
place je dois évidemment que la mcj
monsieur alain pellet le ventre plein
mais tant que je vais sûrement sur mon
fils instagram type que je suis un petit
peu se serait fait que les gens nous
racontent l'histoire des photos le vent
pile après de cette photo que cela que
certaines photos est ce qu'on était
parce qu'on est en norvège
je préfère qu'on pourra voir ce n'est la
dilatation a laissé aller voir mon fils
la daps et le 31 octobre 2010 les cape
town c'est quoi un an avec elle je
t'aime une coupe d'affaires d'affaires
autour de rodez je pense d'enfoncer que
cette photo a été prise le temps en
voyage en norvège avec elisabeth riou
c'est un voyage un voyage pour aller
prendre des photos d'un voyage de
création de contenu en fait bien voyager
création de contenu c'est vraiment pas
comme ça l'air sûr mais internet on peut
aussi parler de la création de contenu
web est oui parlons-en
parce qu'ils en créent du contenu mais
non mais non mais tout à fait sauf que
non c'est justement par lé voile écrit
quoi quoi qu on me prendre des photos
d'aller plus haut mais le truc avec avec
la bête c'est qu'ils avaient la fédé a
fait ses voyages là pour créer du
contenu pour sa marque de maillots de
bain fait que justifier d'une certaine
façon on allait prendre de belles photos
dans des endroits pour créer ce matin
fait que fait que c'est un peu comme ça
que ça se passe sauf curtis ce voyage là
même si on a vu vraiment des beaux
paysages puis évidemment encore une fois
cher en norvège mais je me plains pas
sauf que si on arrive à l'aéroport puis
on a conduit l'équivalent de 52 heures
en sept jours pour aller jusqu'au bout
maintenant on va prendre des photos dans
les plus beaux spots puis quand on prend
une photo c'est horrible on sort du top
en photo pendant ce temps puis ça
c'était cette photo là c'était la fin
d'une journée de ceux où est ce que là
c'est volvo le volant tout le monde est
hérité tout le monde ça les fait chier
d'être le puits moi prendre des photos
de base j'aime vraiment pas ce fake je
dois être vraiment - perfectionniste
maintenant il ya une photo qui prise je
la trouve acceptable c'est cannes et on
s'envole de tir mais c'est pas le cas
pour ma blonde puis c'est bien correct
sauf que là on est à la fin d'une
journée la photo à cannes et pau
était il faisait frais at on était au
nord de la norvège plaute évidemment tu
peux pas être dans un grand manteau
jusqu'à par dessus la table parce que tu
prends des photos hot ont fait d'un
style en fait le tout le monde gèle ses
chiens la photo ap les pas jamais à ma
blonde puis puis on s'est chicané cette
journée le tout après se bat pendant le
photoshoot en fait si je connais pas on
se chicanait en fait pendant que par là
soit aulas est un 2 1 deux arguments
mais si fou bah oui de samedi et ça il a
fallu mois il a fallu que je me réveille
même qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
que tu fais c'est possible mais tu
pourrais facilement organiser un beau
voyage traîner ton appareil pas des
photos au travail peut-être aussi bon
contenu ouais mais si mettons tout appui
moins en partie de ce qu'on faisait sur
ça serait vraiment mieux c'est pour nous
mettons parce que comme je dis moi si
une photo qui est acceptable
ça va être donne moi ce qui est parce
que dans tout qu'est ce que je fais dans
vie je me demande tout le temps c'est
quoi l'intention c'est quoi le bus tu
apportant aussi ça donne puis j'en fais
je dis j'en fais partie ou si jamais des
photos de moi
mais qu'est ce que ça donne de se
prendre en photo
pitel m manga sion qui s adonnent ben
c'est sûr qu'il sait sur qui puis le
petit jeu possible de rationaliser
quelque chose qui est pas rationnel mais
c'est sûr que d'avoir une présence sur
les réseaux sociaux si tu as quelque
chose que tu juges positif à partager
c'est nécessaire d'entretenir une
tribune pour quand tu vas arriver à
partager ça mais si c'est du faux quoi
ben maintenant admettons cette photo là
cette photo a vraiment eu vraiment
beaucoup d'engagement à preuve en est
plein nouveau monde vers mon compte
steam puis ci après avec ce monde là je
les expose à quelque chose qui m'est
vraiment cher comme le véganisme ou
comme des conversations de qualité comme
le podcast je trouve que ça justifie de
jouer un peu
de jouer au jeu d'instagram pour aller
chercher plus de monde qui vont adopter
adapteur adopté ton tac aux dons mais
oui puis par contre tu oublies dans
l'équation tout les gens qui ont checké
c'est depuis qu'ils se sont trouvés dans
mes proches de notre raison c'est ça
c'est juste moi je suis tellement à
questionnement pippa puis en même temps
que moi je fais vraiment l'avocature
parce que je me parle mais je médite et
pour pour tout le bon qu'on partage à
quel point on fout la merde moi je te
donne entièrement raison ce typhon qui
valent bien une personne qui m'a déjà
dit l'historien stadium c'est comme un
téléroman pote punch sans fin c'est
tellement c'est à l'infini puis je me
dis on consomme c'est comme si c'était
de l'or en barre puis je me questionne
vraiment moi en ce moment sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que je trouve que
je pense parce que tu penses pas que
c'est bannir quoi que ce soit ou
d'arrêter d utiliser mais je pense qu'
on manque de raffinement puis on manque
d eau monde de véracité dans notre façon
de partager les tripes
moi je crois que le move d'enlever les
like la part d'instinct g c'est vraiment
un bon un bon jeu c'est vraiment un bon
début j'ai l'impression parce que si tu
trouves
admettons que je suis sur instagram puis
je trouve un contenu que pour moi et
qualité
y a personne qui va me dire que celle
l'époque il est pas un indicatif qui
m'intéresse c'est pas du bon contenu
je peux voir moi-même juste unités moi
même jugé selon ce que moi je recherche
c'est lorsque moi je veux voir ils n'ont
pas de comparer non ça c'est quand même
d'autres indicateurs récents le chiffre
saint graal d'instagram puis le nombre
de cas mortels le nombre de likes les
photos ne voit pas mais mettons une
photo que 55 commentaires vers son truc
un commentaire doute là quelque peu trop
et tu peux t'en douter sauf que tu peux
quand même faire quand on a pignon sur
la qualité de ce que tu vois c'est parce
que pas tout de suite les chiffres qui
quantifie ce que tu vois c'est vrai que
c'est ce qu'on regarde et on promis
c'est tout le charme en 32 langues c'est
quoi ce qu'il faut c'est que non mais
c'est est un questionnement à voir
alexis est revenu sur l'importance de
800 me parlait de de sa nouvelle son
nouvel organisme le ciel c'est justement
dans cette optique là d'essayer de
prendre un petit peu d'aider les gens à
mieux consommer les réseaux sociaux oui
mais c'est toujours les utiliser en fait
parce que justement je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de zones grises pis on se
justifie tout et comme c'est si je
trouve qu'on est dans l'auto indulgence
beaucoup puis j'essaie de faire ce
travail même si c'est vraiment vraiment
du cilss et puis en tant qu'une des
choses que je suis fier s'est mise en
fente j'ai jamais dérailler où j'ai
jamais dérogé dessus puis je suis
vraiment contente d'avoir pu garder ça
pour moi ok gestion que dans le côté si
je m'étais leur façon tellement beau
tellement cute que jessica était complet
mais j'ai encore énormément de travail à
forte dans le ménage de mon compte
personnel 3 par jour sa voix mais bon
perso j beaucoup mais si je disais des
fois quel point on foule a marre de te
dévoile toutefois l'impression dessus
parce qu'il n'ya pas plus de négatif que
posent ces femmes amies je pense qu'ils
ont sans doute pas à quel point
peut-être que oui peut-être que oui mais
en même temps c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment commencé à dire souvent que sur
mon compte instagram c'est que juste que
je trouve beau ou juste le beau j'essaye
vraiment de tapis si ces messages pour
les gens catch qui n'attend maintenant
là
la mer chez eux qui a un enfant qui
vomit sur l'épaule pendant qu'un autre
qui est en train de pleurer en criant
défaite qui tombe ce ton fils doit se
dire rien tabarnak c'est quoi exactement
prime washi sept manches 6-7 marleix qui
était mon ami pompiers des huit semaines
c'est trop petit c'est vraiment
difficile c'est quelque chose que
j'expose pas de seins parce que je
trouve pas ce geste éthiques
de deux parce que je trouve ça hyper
personnel puis de 3 parce que quand
j'étais avec mes enfants je prends pas
des photos je passe mon cell plus
possible que j'ai ce n est vraiment
présente à un fait qui a tendance à nous
celle fille était j'ai pas beaucoup de
photos de méfait en fait à la base dans
mon cell parce que j'y pense pas
ironiquement alors que dans la vie je
fais ce mais c'est ça j'ai l'impression
que peut-être jamais eu un impact
négatif sur certaines femmes qui sont
dans une mauvaise passe ou parce que moi
des fois je vais me comparer puis moi je
me sentir comme la com de la grosse
merde en regardant le fils de quelqu'un
d'autre
malgré le message que je dis aujourd'hui
dit qu'il faut que je me rappelle que ça
c'est pas la vie que fait je pense quand
je pense que ça fout l'anxiété à
beaucoup plus de gens qu'on pense et moi
et toi et tout le monde qui sur les
réseaux sociaux
probablement je prends par contre c'est
encore une fois faut essayer de se
rappeler que kitty instagram
initialement c'était une plateforme pour
partager des belles photos le beau et
partager quelque chose que toi que moins
que lui il trouve beau puis c'est
correct et si tu partages le boom après
ça je pense qu'il ya une scierie
question de contexte qui est important à
prendre en considération est ce que le
bout c'est du vrai c est ce que c est ce
que on est en train de remplir qu'un
malheureux pendant le shoot ou est ce
qu'on aura des chicanes et pendant un
jour tout est ce qu en ce moment je fais
bob je devrais en train par quelque
chose de plus importante entre le bo
puis le vrai y est quand même le nord
jouit je pense qu'on devrait focaliser
sur les deux hommes une tente et c'est
très difficile pour sa suprématie c'est
un bon questionnement avoir au moins
de plus en plus maintenant au moins
j'imagine que l'authenticité ça c'est
une autre question est-ce que
l'authenticité célèbre le dentiste et la
trend d'authenticité sur l'internet est
ce que c'est la vraie authenticité
l'état de ses forces et ses rangs petit
quand j'ai fait de parts et authentique
seul sait ce que le mot galvaudé le mont
d'or à tous et le nouveau tchad mais si
maman tu aimais tant que justement
méthode poster des photos de ton bébé
qui de vomi sur l'épaule pilot type là
dessus ça reste qu' il ya eu une mise en
scène parce qu'il ya un cada qui est
sorti indemne et le triple saut marc
toucher les couleurs de ta photo pi
active même je veux montrer tes moment
de vulnérabilité août et maman - beauté
mois - si c'est quand même toit qui fuit
le terme tout choisi qu'est ce que tu
manges quand même des moments souvent
plus dj pareil chaque mois j'essaie
d'enlever tout ça j'essaye vraiment de
garder juste ce que je sache
- tu assumes existait je place mes [ __ ]
et des fois hors des photos de famille
coûte et je prends une photo jiaqi que
j'ai un événement qui se prend mon cell
4 secondes postée comme data loss
comprenait une photo avec un kodak et sa
part excessive ces photos là mais tige
j'essaye de parce que c'est pas vrai que
c'est ça tout stg même même les maires
qui qui qui parle d'à quel point c'est
dur est morte et comme tu dis c'est
stage'' aussi en quelques sortes à
choisi de parler des affaires disent ils
mais les stg pareil puis a choisi
d'ajouter nous devons y mettre quoi tes
jeudi même les recettes le train des
recettes est quand même la plus belle
photo de ta race et de la ligne e place
est possible d'un plus beau c'est avec
la plus belle lumière le cinéma mais
toujours vivant c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut juste pas parlé d'
authenticité puis de vraie vie quand on
parle de réseaux sociaux il y aurait
comme déjà pas mal moins de problèmes et
d'attentes
si on assume lequel elle révise pose pas
les réseaux sociaux là on va tous se
portait un petit peu mieux et est même
on peut l'assumer tu mets ton moi je le
sais oui c'est juste quand j'en ai fait
des beaux voyages le propofol six est
pas qu une banque sur ses c'est le fun
mais chez qui s'est passé parce que
salarié mais même moi qui 6
quand je vois quelqu'un qui est à tahiti
dans l'eau bleue chacun
axa les ratés échec c'est quoi qui s'est
passé pour prendre la photo pour 10 48
millions qu'ils sont les trois quarts du
temps sont en chambre d'hôtel à éditer
sur lightroom pitt c était moi je me
souviens avant même que tu fasses aude
et si tu me parles de ton ami que sa
blonde influence à les battre
je me souviens tu avais le discours est
haute
ils sont payés pour voyager l'esprit ce
continent c'est sans payer pour voyager
ils vont partout qu'ils s'adorent fou ce
qu'ils font et d un peu fait berné paris
hilton adultes étaient pourtant jeudi
encore alors quand je vois quelqu'un qui
paient pour voyager genre mais c'est
quand même apprécié le rationalisme
qu'est ce qu'il fout d'être payé pour
c'est quand il fait quelque chose qui
qui vient là bas comme au delà de toutes
les voyages aux affaires c'est quand tu
reçois un chèque parce que tu as fait
quelque chose qui est des demandes ou
que puis qu'il ya eu zéro compromis le
parce que je trouve qu'on est toujours
un compromis c'est sale affaire c'est ça
le mot je pense on est constamment dans
le compromis on dire qu'il y est mais
l'outil en ce moment ça se passe mal
mais si messaoud bella aux dépens de sun
va au moins offert ce alors qui est pour
moi c'est comme un beau vers dole qui a
une petite goutte de colorant noah ont
loué grise comme siguiri un stoppeur
ouais tiens quand et que tout le temps
tu es valeur des coûts toujours ta
petite voix intérieure tant que feeling
faut choisir soit je parlais tout ce qui
peut comme pas vraiment rompu parce que
si ça marche ça marche parfaitement
concordance avec avec des variables ça
marche pas bête idéaux mais au moins je
suis pas dans quelque chose qui est avec
le cheval a les outils ou ge
quant au dessus il ya aussi il ya une
différence entre quelqu'un qui fait
quelque chose avec une intention
parfaite psychologist est parfait mais
il ya aussi des gens qui fondent étions
vraiment une intention parfaite mais qui
font quelque chose d'un parfait était
pour moi ce qui est le plus important
c'est vraiment l'intention pas normal
le temps mais je pense que si tout le
monde on se nettoie et puis on fait du
ménage qu'on essaye d'être le plus en
plus sincère tout en fera pas toujours
des affaires parfaite mais au moins tu y
vas avoir l'intention c'est tellement
importante et j'imagine que cette belle
santé quand vous prenez la chute que tu
fais ce que tu dis si tu fais pas une
chose que moi et de la fin que j'ai fait
je dis astuces avait fait qu'est-ce que
je te demande et parce que sans la vôtre
justement tu t'es tu es toujours
vraiment écouté il faut pas écouter
nommé coo ok ça laisse un petit écouter
toi même puisqu'elle trouve à part
ajouté ressemble vraiment pis
parfaitement en concordance avec des
valeurs août - la majorité des termites
des moments où est ce que justement tu
étais pas écouté tout le regretter wei
vraiment une question vraiment surtout
au début quand on n'a pas trouvé par
jour ça a été super vite je me disais
wow faudrait qu'on se calme qu'on règle
notre relation d'amour jeu qu'après ça
et je me suis pas écouté après ça allait
tellement bien les magazines je passais
des cats a six magazines parmi ges avec
sa part les projets savez que j'ai fait
toi j'ai regretté je passais à 4 estime
t dans mon désir de tellement fait
offrir du bon contenu un moment donné un
maximum de productions tu peux faire par
ami le dj la qualité va être diluée à
moins que si ça fait que je n'y a pas
une chose que j'ai faite comme ce qu'est
cédé 0 c'est parti c'est ce souci
enfin j'espère non c'est un peu un petit
peu comment est-ce que commence que
trois fois par jour ça a commencé
et à cause d'un arrêt xi et jj vraiment
eu une période de ma vie où la beauté
comme amour n y pas ce que j'aime manger
mais j'avais peur de grossir
j'ai vraiment des troubles du
comportement alimentaire puis un certain
point
je consultais jeu ouais je consultais je
consulte encore je suis personne qui
consulte
je pense que on peut jamais trop parler
même quand ça va bien les chevaux puis
je commencer à régler tout simplement
néji recommence à manger trois fois par
jour puis j'ai rencontré alex puis j'ai
commencé à cuisiner j'ai toute crise est
là mais cloche était plus capable je
voulais je voulais avoir le contrôle sur
ma vie pour le faire un petit projet
sans rayonner ça fait jaser à l'excès
regard je veux partir un blog de bourse
et 0,2 lamia non un million mais c'est
ce que je veux faire juste ma musique sa
tante prend les photos fait qu' il dit
oui fait que jacques faudrait trouver un
nom je vous fan page facebook le fait
que je propose est plein on kitchenette
recette si tu sais que je fais à trois
fois par jour je mange trop beau par
jour tellement fière de manger trop par
jour puis je vois parler des troubles
alimentaires puis je mettrai pas de tes
deux chiffres des valeurs nutritives
soit parce que moi je regarde évidemment
les calories puisse calculer tout est
qu'eric starks vraiment laid comme non
c'est que oui ok qui est le lendemain je
peux y était ou même texte 10,3 par jour
c'est bon je vois sur facebook je fais
la page 3 fois par jour je mets ma
première recette est ingrat nous le puis
c'est parti comme ça c'est vraiment
aussi simple que ça puis on y devenu un
peu fou et on s'était mis à créer à
créer https ça implique tellement de
choses à acheter des accessoires phares
à cette photo s'acheter sa caméra et dvd
beltas du beau temps sur un trou sans
fond là une fonction là dedans
ouaip ici c'est nous mais ça coûte cher
d'épicerie ça coûte cher at avec le 19
vous commencez à faut essayer des
finances totti puis lui il y avait eu un
héritage qu'il avait fait vivre pendant
un homme de mon côté j'avais un peu
d'argent de côté le fait qu'on n'a pas
eu de salaire dont un but
puis de fil en aiguille après une
partenaire que se sont joints à nous est
celle d'or qui était notre premier
client qui a financé nos capsules puis
après ça pousse à l'escaladé vraiment
vite on est passé de
deux personnels 15-18 le temps qui m'est
on les amène au premier set après un
mois trois par jour parce qu'il y avait
des jeunes de réponse le faut nous
battre comme du processeur qui ont
enlevé deux autres on n'a pas cédé comme
un phare à cent mille ans comme un ou
deux mois ouais ça l'est comme exploser
deux savent pas ce que c'est attribuable
à quoi mme et en même temps que
maintenant tu regarde en arrière c'est
dire qu'il se sait c'était dessus le
times fait la même chose deux ans plus
tard et pas fonctionné il y en a
vraiment beaucoup maintenant toi y en a
beaucoup beaucoup puis mais je pense que
c'est une partie de alex moines duo les
jeunes trouvent et comique worship ils y
ont adopté le duo il ya un autre volet
aux nouveautés de la qualité du contenu
légende tester les recettes ça marche
elle est juste et bon fait que le temps
et c'est une poule b le temps fait deux
trois quatre vingts pis je pense que
c'est vraiment ces deux clubs si les
gens me disent tu parce qu'ils étaient
connus à la base puis je dis oui moi
même temps ça aurait pu faire le
contraire puis vraiment faire en sorte
qu est ce qu on en fait pas vraiment ça
que je m'embarquais ouais pisar et fait
mauvaise presse dans mon art et
ridiculise y trouvera par jour alors que
ça le ca s'est pas passé heureusement le
tant mieux mais tu es je pense que c'est
une question de chance qui travaille
comme infirmier voué au début vous
publiez mois la mettons le comme vous
publiez de récession faisait tellement
le j'en faisais tellement tellement
tellement qui est erratique et il
connaissait me proportion par cars 2
avant la publier prendre la photo le taf
trois fois je faisais déjà fait je
faisais mettons un test au début un
deuxième thèse souvent pleins seuls
troisièmes si c'était vraiment sacoche
le shoot et puis après ça tombait à 2
puis certaines recettes à prêter quand
ta formule de base de travaux par jour
l'été metal et moi fut de trois par jour
c'est la même recette de base toujours
le change des trucs fait qd il y en a
des fois que j'ai pu besoin de tester
trois fois que je le sais que ça vaut
fonctionnalité fait que
avec l'expérience puisque maintenant
j'ai eu des déchets fossiles à temps
plein à l'inter n'en développe des
recettes dont on vient bon avec le temps
si on enfin la seule justice sur cette
base il y avait plus de travail petit
viiip s'est éteint à kiel je pense que
votre signature esthétique aussi
vraiment beaucoup joué le parce que
c'est vraiment beau
ouais c'est tout mais d'ivoire les je me
questionne par rapport à ça parce que je
me dis je veux pas que les gens
ressentent une pression quand ils voient
trop beau par jour puis je veux jeu sans
lequel j'arrive à un point où faut que
je dédie du temps dans la création de
recettes encore si c'est accessible mais
encore plus si proche si proche du proc
je me rends compte que moi j'arrive
chinois maison que j'ai même pas le
temps de cuisiner avec deux enfants
moi j'ai un bébé broche je peux rien
faire pis les soupers préférée de ma
fille c'est les soupers surprise parce
que c'est d'y croire que avec des boîtes
de fromage qui est un truc congelé pour
pourrait j'y pense parce que dans la
réalité là il ya des soirs où est-ce que
j'ai juste la possibilité de france en
termes d'étapes de fait que j'ai envie
de m'adresser à ceux du tout
l'impression que mettons ça fait 80 ses
droits par jour ça va faire tant que les
gens cuisinent petit plus aujourd'hui du
moins est ce que la demande du
prêt-à-manger est vraiment en croissance
et je pense que les gens de plus en plus
veulent bien manger c'est ça je pense
qu'il y avait vraiment une
conscientisation à ce niveau là mais
est-ce cuisine plus je sais pas plus
si je pense que quand j'ai passé trois
par jour oui mais qu'en ce moment il ya
un besoin d'avoir un offre nouveau du
doigt les gens manquent d'eau car les
gens manquent beaucoup tu as fait que
j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont peut-être
plus cuisiner à fin de semaine oui mais
qu'est la semaine ou pour les lunch ils
vont aller vraiment avoir là-dessus
prêtes-à-manger parce qu'il ya une chose
qui a mis hors de tout doute c'est que
les gens ont plus cuisiner gosse à tout
défi était de plus en plus une traînée
c'est beaucoup seul discours aussi de
ses méthodes quatre cas de nouveau guide
alimentaire canadien où tous les
antisionistes maintenance et les
recommandations sipa mais non
ce que je trouve fabuleux
puis c'est ça qu'on se comprend et qui
surtout j'espère qu'il ya des gens qui
ont qui ont que j'ai décomplexifier ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont des complexes à
manger qui on parle de manger c'est
compliqué de manger qui y vont par deux
grosses pierres qui on parle d avoir des
boutons et c c est fini mais on se doute
pas à quel point en oeuvre je reçois des
messages c'est super mamie se trouvent
par jour le focus est pas justement
santé je vois pas ce que tu veux un peu
évacuer la pression de bien manger
qu'elle arrive de ce2 quand même eu un
effet c'est sur le très bénéfiques sur
la santé publique le parce que les gens
ont cuisiné puis on mangeait plus tôt
qu'elle mangeait transformer ils ont
mangé des vrais aliments mais je pense
que oui puis je suis vraiment jamais de
moi je suis vraiment fier de cette on a
cinq millions de clics par mois et que
j'ai c'est que c'est fou seul sur mon
set la gestique ceci dit monique cuisine
je trouve ça vraiment fun puis aussi le
thé le volet de notre bout de secte et
on est vraiment s'arrête tellement été
facile pour moi de me mettre multi
riches avec des produits fait en chine
tellement facile magenta fi nancer sais
je suis vraiment fier d'avoir tenu mon
but pour les produits québécois tout est
fait au québec on a tout le temps
d'accord deux passes question fournit
pas mais c'est fait cible c'est je suis
vraiment vraiment vraiment fier d'être
un petit bâtiment est à votre nom moi
vraiment piqué ce que commun est-ce que
tu as une image de wes que tu veux que
trois fois par jour aïe j'ai jamais eu
j'ai jamais été capable d'envié le même
huit ans la mesure où ce que je veux
être dans un an
parce que on dirait que tout arrive de
face
j'ai tout dans les surprises dans ma vie
je m'entraîne travailler sur une
nouvelle surprise
deux nouvelles sur prêts
ce qu'il ya deux mois je savais pas ce
qui allait se passer fait me projeter
dans cinq ans je pense ça donne
absolument rien parce que c'est
tellement un milieu où c'est selon les
circonstances puis les gens qui te rends
compte et fait que non moi tant qu a
nettement chuté une mère qui présente
qui était dans sa présence si aucun
raffinement dans ma présence avec mes
enfants le n'importe quoi je dois faire
qu'ils vont me permettre ce dans la vie
je dois être content
c'est vraiment mon ciel bull est une
bonne mois puis est ce que est ce que tu
es ce que tu as tu du carré des rêves de
deux peut-être avoir une émission à de
la télé c'est ok c'est quelque chose qui
qui qui serait naturel pour trois par
jour
ouais ok y'a plein de monde qui que oui
on verra qu'est ce qu'elle fout on va
voir qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent pas des
questions
[Rires]
c'est quelque chose qui quittent et kaki
qui serait hyper en lien avec les
valeurs puis la mission trouve par jour
de juste parce qu'on fait sur un autre
médium d'enfants rsa l'afub seront
dévoilés par sa maman ainsi vraiment un
débutant
moi j'ai tellement un niveau bas mais
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose qui
fait qui parce que parce que moi mettons
que je me mette en place d'un producteur
télé peas et le show que je veux
produire c'est sur les mégots s'effondre
euros par jour
[Rires]
c'est que bon gré une chance que je
pense que les gens aiment c'est l'humour
dont trois par jour parce que c'est
vraiment tant qu'anti tchèque le vi de
vitry bop ze meka cross qu'utile il
continue piqué tchèque un tracé en hydro
dommage avec alex et drôle mais c'est un
peu une étape ce qui se voit une étape à
la fois qui est serait pointé ville est
un show que j'ai faite sur les raisons
de la bâtisse parce que j'avais une
boîte sec 3 par jour puis c'est du pur
divertissement l'été ça fait du bien un
peu de légèreté pillet toute mon équipe
sont drôles il fallut mot widmark été
une des choses qui nous a aidés à passer
à travers nos épreuves alex et moi et
puis encore aujourd'hui comme parent
s'est créé
on dit que c'est ça fait but faux fous
rires faut savoir rire de nous sinon
j'ai pas si vous vous aimez c'est rire
de vous c'est la meilleure et moins
bouger bouger beaucoup d'autodérision
tout a pas beaucoup de temps dès
maintenant travailler la 600ème
passerait rire de toi ben juste je le
fais pas souvent non pas c'est tellement
drôle j'aime tellement genève et à bâle
on met tout à fait je suis d'accord
d'accord qui devrait venir de moi plus
j'aime aussi qu'on parle la musique
oui parce que c'est tellement drôle
parce que c'est nous on a la chance
d'avoir connu la marie lou chanteuse
[Musique]
important matériel non mais attends le
pass le style et les l'écart avec garou
et je me rappelle bien ils étaient des
carouges toi ouais ouais mais en fait
c'est que pour moi il ya deux volets la
seule il ya ce qu'on a vu puisque j'ai
vécu l'affecter comme je pas fier du
matériel
ok
un petit j'ai mangé avec les boss de
sony music qui me disent qu'il faut que
je performe sinon tu es gimont mosquée
pour cet album quand j'avais tout ça
n'aura pas au début ouais ça peut être
si comme un lot de faire la passe que tu
qualifierait le milieu puis août et la
placidité de mal si complètement
oui c'est complètement malsain ne sais
pas c'est pas un individu un individu un
souvent c'est ça aussi une t on dit
l'une gagne deux jeunes locales tous les
prendre seul coup ça fait vingt dix ans
mais en gagnant trek ça devient une
jungle c'est un peu ça je trouve les
milieux artistiques purement que ça l'à
beaucoup évolué avec les réseaux sociaux
puissent comme si à moins de cachette je
sais pas mais qu'est ce que j'ai pu voir
dans la ville de puteaux sa boule non un
peu c'est ce qui en fait c'est pour ça
qu'elle est trop bas les menteurs gym 6
et 10 ans que je consulte ce je
considère que je pense une bonne
j'ai fait énormément de travail puis
chez une personne qui heureuse
aujourd'hui mais comme ça me coûte
vraiment cher tout seul tu es j'étais
complètement isolée n'allait pas à
l'école et je t'avais des professeurs
privés camp qui se passait rien pendant
deux mois j'étais chez nous à à rien
faire pendant tout le monde va à l'école
c'est faux quand ces isolants c'est des
perçu comme un produit mais oui pis en
plus de ça tout les jeunes qui rit toi
parce que ils ont tissé un mécanisme de
défense les gestes que je me fonds c'est
facile d'acheter une proie facile
en même temps mystérieuse parce que les
gens ils se demandaient et tisci
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'a fait effecté les
mon parcours autant
avec les petits gangs et les petits
triste épisode je sais ça fait que je
suis je suis pas fier de ce que j'ai
fait but également parce que c'est un
peu vite mais je suis fier de ce qu'est
ce que j'ai fait humainement de tout
sauter avec le temps c'est encore la
dichotomie entre le paraître est ce que
c'est vraiment comparaître les réseaux
sociaux mais t'avais delà d'avoir la
belle carrière joens et dont
l'incroyable qu'est ce qu'elle vit dans
le fond j'imagine que malheureuses bêtes
et quand tu vois c'est ça tout le temps
quand je partais je partais un mois deux
mois d'été à paris marseille ça sonne
superbe il est comme moi j'avais le goût
de revenir ici et j'ai vécu des j'ai
vécu des super belle affaire
professionnellement par an ça m'a donné
de l'expérience plus mais je te dirais
que au niveau de la musique c'est en ce
moment dans ma vie que j'en fais le plus
piqué street heureuse ben oui mais il
est encore là mais c'est tout récemment
qu'il y à force de me guérir tout seul
je me suis monté un studio dans ma
chambre puis je suis jamais fait autant
musique même quand j'en faisais
publiquement alors parce que je suis là
j'ai vraiment si bon et piloter parce
qu'à l'époque j'avais 12 ans je n'étais
pas trop équipée non non j'y arrivais
pas je recevais des trucs souvent je
ramassais les retail de céline chez dans
le livre de rené put céline fait que
souvent les tout cas prenez pas beloeil
me refiler dont les tradi visible c'est
une anglophone
c'est comme les s'est quand même passé
tel évènement tapez sol le vêtement
c'est que moi je veux plus c'est pas que
c'est de la mer métier car soit 400 par
année que je sens choisir 10 bien
évidemment qui effectue ce n'était pas
mauvais le
mais c'était surtout le meilleur en
anglais le cas que ces deux-là du steak
ans à pauline coche en dessous mais mais
mais si ça fait que 50 des faits que là
tu joue de la musique ou la détention
jld écrit tellement là j'écris vraiment
beaucoup on dirait que j'ai montré que
gm d'ouvrir une chaîne jason chapleau
il s assoit ce que quelqu'un m'attende
sa belle j'en ai aucune idée
on va voir on va voir mais je pense que
c'est ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie de
plus beau dans ce sens parce que si je
trouve que c'est bon dans ce sens est ce
que ça veut dire non mais pour moi tout
ce cheminement depuis que je fasse
insulter et quelque chose il ya quelque
chose de touchant en fait c'est pas beau
c'est touchant je pense que c'est ce que
j'ai fait quelques changements dans ma
carrière
ce qui évidemment me ressemble plus
parce que quand je chantais tuer comme
ça fait joli but j'ai jeté juste la
liste des mots qui remettait un bouge
pas des mots j'ai croisé garou
d'ailleurs y est comme un mois moi tu
veux c'est tellement drôle parce que je
tue le tue la bête tu l'as wihr vue
qu'eric toutefois invité j'ai quand même
parti en tournée avec en france 7h20
c'est drôle c'est très très drôle piet
ça m'a vraiment fait comme moi où j'ai
eu deux vies ouais c'est ce statut
l'impression que c'est la même personne
non vrai maintenant
enfin patrick g je me suis plu tant que
je me souviens tout mais on dirait que
c'est pas moi que tu y es tu quelque
chose qui est qu'un message ça fait non
nathan est un événement et précis ou une
anecdote quelque chose qui karnataka
votre sainteté ramené de fait et c'est
pas c'est pas moi c'est pas qui je rate
pas ben c'est qu'à un moment donné à
force de consultations j'ai réalisé que
j'étais allé trop loin déjà fait que si
un paquet d'affaires qui au fil des
années
haman adji mines une barrière mais ces
acquis c'est pas normal de se sentir
comme ça c'est pour moi c'était
un homme d'être toujours être en mode de
représentation de performer des deux
ports le droit d'être malade parce qu'il
ya une date qui bout qui depuis six mois
puis le site de la gastro en crystal
systems pas réalité c'était mais
honnêtement je regarde où je me dis si
ma fille me donner à chante puisqu'elle
à la gastro quand même si sa date ça
fait six mois qu'ils aient bouquet je
manque alice est malade avant les
couches et puis je vais prendre soin de
son homme à ma petite fille de son côté
mais moi j'ai j pas eu accès à ces comme
si marie lou n'était pas une priorité
la carrière de mario et entre orthez
puis je peux pas en vouloir à mes
parents parce que mes parents
honnêtement reste que c'est
impressionnant pour une fille de 14 ans
mais c'est quand même impressionnant
pareil pour une fille un représentant de
viande hachée géo pis une caissière de
la caisse desjardins qui arrive dans ce
milieu est pour mais je décris mais tout
ça c'est super impressionnant répit moi
je dirais oui je vais faire ça passe qui
est installé c'est ce que tu connais
c'est juste complètement fou pis si ça
mais je sais ce que c'est parfois aussi
mes filles avec quelconque tard
artistiquement du seigneur que je le
protégerai plus que ça
parce que tu le vécu mais c'est vraiment
pas tu es ce que tu disais de c'est tout
ce que je connaissais mais tombe se sait
c'est un mal qui fréquent dans la
société maintenant de dans quelque chose
mais tant que dans une relation toxique
le tueur est dedans parce que c'est tout
ce que tu connais c'est pas que si tu
sors de l'eau du savon dove sur le coup
mais qu'après mais c'est pour ça que je
trouve que la guérison passe par la
consultation pas juste d'un préfet d'un
professionnel mais tout le monde qu'on
se parle mais quand ces coteaux site et
j'ai l'impression qu'on manque de mon
manque de consultation dans nos vies
tout le monde c'est comme si on
compartimente on dit même dans les
familles comme un deep ocean mamie ou du
pot cette attente ou du poste à 6 ou 10
postes alors que pour quartz et on
devrait toutes ces idées puissent parler
comme un concept qui est peu tabou pour
justement enlever toutes les choses que
vous me suivez ici pour qu'on connaisse
pour qu'on établisse des normes qu'est
ce qui est normal qu est-ce qu il est
pas qu est-ce qui parce qu'ils passent
pas parce qu'au fond nous on le sait on
sait qu est ce qui est bon on sait qu
est-ce qui et malté cancon quand qu'on
s'instruit qu'on se parle puisqu'elle
nous comme adultes aimer les enfants ont
besoin d'avoir des adultes autour d'eux
qu'ils se parlent
pour ce que moi ma famille en ce moment
leur mi mai deux filles ont deux papas
pisser fois qu'ils ont mais m
j'en appelle papa alex papa à cake le
groupe naval a key lime à petit rosa à
l'appel à l'aide champagne papa cancale
voix pcc comme ces deux figures ya papa
biologique ne peut pas de coeur puis je
veux qu'elle ait deux papas soit
impliqué au même titre dans la vie de
mes enfants je pense qu'en partie
compartiment des toits ton papa
biologique s'il lui fait clair avec moi
puis lui petit jard sopi on est on est
on va être dans l'erreur des fois on va
se tromper on voit mes crimes ont créé
une communauté peu de cash est simple ça
fait du bien pour des enfants
non c'est ce qui rend ces balles mais
aussi les deux grillages
des mosquées mais pourquoi qui en aurait
fait dans tes bébittes oui c'est sûr
mais si tu regardes ultime olympique et
tu veux que ses deux enfants là aient
l'impression qu'ils ont toute la place
égale mais assume qu'on ait divorcé puis
toi assume qui était avec une femme qui
s'est divorcé puis j'ai jamais eu besoin
de recettes discours là ça s'est fait
naturellement mais notre situation c'est
ce qu'est ce qu'on veut puis comment
qu'on pense que c'est mieux de lviv
on est toutes des personnes saines
d'esprit heureusement donc on peut se
permettre d'impliquer tout le monde
puisque tout le monde se parle que moi
je piquais un discours techinque les
enfants petits gel c'est que ma plus
jeune quand que jane ou en valais avec
son papa biologique avoue mme royal et
puis c'est correct et yvon on va se
parler c'est bizarre pour du monde mais
nous c'est ça parce qu'on décide
vraiment d'offrir à nos enfants quelque
chose d'uniformes de d'égal
pis des pires même 10 copies je vais
tout courant dès qu'est ce qui se passe
quand il était chez lui depuis que je
veux qu'ils soient au courant que ce qui
se passe de nos défis pour qu'on on
continue à les travailler pas
compartimentée ballon on est rendu là
dans le développement telles qualités
août on le sait tellement on travaille
la patience 6 au courant de tout ce
qu'on se parle comme parenté qu'il ya
une constance puis je pense qu'ils
étaient je pense que l'amélioration du
monde que ça va passer par l'éducation
des enfants pile on a toute une
responsabilité même si vous n'avez pas
d'enfants les enfants autour de vous ont
besoin de voter on a une responsabilité
puis à travers les réseaux sociaux si
c'est pour ça que je parlais d'un
message phréatiques ont on arrête de
vendre la salade pour venir justement
attaqué hier ses rangs des exemples
d'enfants vedette qui est tout va bien
mais qu'est que ça les phoques pop leur
développement me sens je ne sais pas qui
c'est arrivé mais c'est quand quand tu
passes béton justement les enfants fait
d'être les outils méthodes et justin
bieber ou les libres disputée où les
michael jackson c est ce qui est des
exemples existent ils sont calmes et
honteuse tembely qui me semble tanguer
qu'avec mon quart temps quand on connaît
pas sa vie privée mais me semble que si
un enfant vit pas sa jeunesse il ya un
garde
j'ai l'impression des cicatrices j'ai
l'impression que on parle jamais de
l'homme des gens le métro on vit on est
avec une énorme
puis je pense qu est ce qui arrive puis
il ya des gens qui verbal aussi en
allant à l'école père n'ayant pas
recours pour mal mais je pense que c'est
le fait que il ya tellement trop de
temps on s'adresse pas à l'homme des six
de ses enfants le pis on farsi leur
crâne à s'occuper avec autre chose que
leur instinct que leur leur qualité du
kart dans le fond si je le vois ce qui
sécurise mes enfants dans la ville c'est
quand je m'adresse à ceux ci c'est
vraiment jeu set et quand quand ma fille
a démentit pas envie de me séparer
aujourd'hui pong est avec toi
aujourd'hui toute la journée tu es la
seule chose qui nous rice et pas de
bellegarde c'est comme se laver se dire
on travaille chacun de notre bord
aujourd'hui maman à s'en vont développer
des qualités qui doivent aller
développer des qualités pleut à la
fondation se retrouve le pied en passant
par les le pense à moi aujourd'hui puis
moi je pense à toi puis on se voit
tantôt rauque et qui plus est remonté à
la une mission du coeur le clic t elle
quelque chose afin aujourd'hui puis à
s'extraire à travailler là dessus aussi
pis moi comme je tenterai de gérer une
situation mais qu'un employé un collègue
chose une je pense à ma fille avait
peut-être fier que j'ai traité ça comme
ça puis on se retrouve le sopi son âme
on était en contact puis elle est
nourrie t2 comprend fake
j'ai l'impression que c'est par là que
ça passe le bonheur qu'il est qu'il est
un petit jeu benoit parfaite je fais pas
une affaire qui sont sûrement pas top et
j'essaye mais mais je pense qu'il faut
nourrir ces enveloppes et les enfants
avaient dépensé ici s'exclame un petit
peu du puits peuvent sauter même
tellement la place est tellement pour
tout le reste puis le par ipe ceux qui
on s'adresse fois ci trop d'adultes qui
vivent départ de ceux qui sont
dépendants d'un enfant si oui qu'est-ce
que ce dernier est trop à dire qui les
attire tous les adultes qui avaient
autour leur salaire et pays avec 10 par
la carrière d'un enfant mais si ça fait
qu' on voit plus l'homme des stands
comment qui santé c'est comme performe
l'équipe qui digérait dans le fond tout
ce qu'ils ont essayé d'appliquer le mot
là la recette céline le modèle céline à
toi qui crée une deuxième ou une
nouvelle je sais pas il faut vraiment
faire attention parce que c'est comme je
jette en tout c'est pas les individus
c'est le sait le mieux rassembler ouais
c'est ça c'est que si chaque personne
avec moi avait sincèrement un désir de
savoir si ça va tu t'es tu coréen kt
remake mais dans le fond c'est être
diluée par huit autres personnes 8
si on fallait qu'on vante en album et il
ya trop il ya trop en fait il y avait
trop d'intermédiaires pour faire en
sorte que vraiment je me sens en
sécurité
puis c'est sûr que c'est malsain qu'un
quiconque un parfum et génèrent des
revenus pour une entreprise une maison
disque où tout s est bien il sait se dit
mme et on l'a fait que ça commençait à
12 ans à peu près à peu près puis ça
s'est terminé 1 re mi temps 14 quel est
le switch peu près avant juste avant
trois fois par jour j'ai comme fait un
dernier album que j'ai comme couilles
crime était aussi marqué l'année 2010
1011 petit tu fais que ça fait ça fait
juste avant trois fois par jour métier
ça fait déjà une couple d'années que je
m'étais dit ceci est tout à la fois le
désir de dépôt drivée par franchement sa
carrière jusqu'à institutions par jour
drive plus oui mais je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qui fait que j'ai tout le
temps des bombes de projets qui m'arrive
qui fait que sa grosse île du messti
pour moi qui
dans une entrevue un plaisir qui était
mal à l'aise avec les mots entrepreneurs
oui il est un modèle d'entreprenariat
mais considère peu d'entrepreneurs
ben je considère peut-être que je les
dis mais vraiment une artiste en fait
une artiste qui veut être indépendant
donc ça égale entrepreneurs comme pas le
choix mais je suis pas entrepreneur je
devine de plus en plus à l'aise avec le
terme passe contrée que l'on entend
tellement souvent mais moi je suis une
artiste je vais être indépendante
je veux offrir mais c'est ça je pense
que tu mets le doigt dessus tu veux
faire valoir indépendante peu importe
c'est quoi la plateforme tu deviens
entre eux n'en veut pas d'entreprendre
sa carrière
exact puis moi en plus ça me stimule
tellement d'avoir depuis juin prochain
que le mot employé
je les appelle tout le temps mes
collègues ont très peu juste pourquoi
mais reste que c'est des employés puis
j'ai toujours ce tellement gratifiant de
leur offrir un job que je vois qui
rentrent le matin ils sont contents de
leur l'autre puis on est enfin puis ont
droit à des avantages qui dissipe des
sushis comme moi aussi j nage fait
qu'est ce que j'aime j'aime la job à des
gens dans un contexte qui je crois est
quand même sens y ait de l'écouté du
respect fait que ses juges
j'adore en ce moment j'adore ma vie et
je peux parler trouvaient toujours des
défis tu sais mais je suis vraiment une
personne qui tu parles tu parle beaucoup
depuis tantôt de communication fait que
ce soit de bien communiquer avec des
faits bien communiquer avec était de
alex qui ont partagé la vie de
communiquer avec des employés la
communication on en parle des fois dans
le podcast puis de plus en plus je
réalise à quel point c'est la chose la
plus importante dans toutes les
relations
c'est un ordre parce que je pense
qu'avant de communiquer faut qu'ils
comprennent comment sans toi ouais ouais
c'est un examen de conscience à faire à
chaque jour j'ai l'impression que c'est
un truc et moi faut que je travaille
faut que je m'arrête pour voir où je me
situe pour mieux communiquer justement
mais c'est off c'est vraiment eu ces
lézards été enlevé on ne fait pas des
cons à deux secondes regarder mon
autorité que leur cellulaire
red bull lumière rouge il ya des gens
qui sont pas garde attendre la fin de la
lumière rouge sang c'est sans regarder
l'heure seulement la selle c'est faux
j'ai les journées mosquera samaké pts et
puis ça fait en sorte qu'on communique
cultes comme les coupures on laisse pas
aussi c'est juste à temps dans une salle
d'attenté pendant dix minutes il rien
faire une de l'ennui mais de l'ennui une
joie des méditations casement qui vient
piquer un peu de ménage dans ta tête je
pense et des enfants à nantes
quand tu es constamment stimulé t'as pas
le temps de faire ce ménage le data de
justice
c'est pourquoi on en parle on a parlé
avec un vidéo podcastée de jeu se lever
le matin réfléchir qui c'est quoi les
jours que j'ai enfin aujourd'hui puis où
c'est quelque chose qui m'angoisse bien
juste lit comme les régler un peu la
tacle j'avais le temps passe
garde ta boule d'angoissé dans ton
vampires pour ce qui choque que je
consulte dans la vie parce que c'est
comme pour moi une façon de m'aider à le
faire mais c'est je pense à prendre
discipline pour l'intégrer au quotidien
ça c'est un demi bon gros défi surtout
avec les enfants parce que je me couche
en même temps qu aujourd'hui il me
réveille le matin s'est fixé comme si
j'ai pote débreak pige gagne mon à avoir
des breaks temime
même dans les relations de couple dès
fois de de prendre une mine du temps ce
sa faute a fait du bien et je le fais
pas je suis incapable de faire garder
mes enfants sujets comme un problème
refuge
je veux trop être tellement sacoche je
veux jouer j'ai fait des enfants je suis
même en occuper ses com
mais des fois ça ferait du bien de juste
une nuit maman prend les je vais aller
dormir puis avec monture n'envoie jamais
travaillé je suis épuisée défaut de
vouloir que tout soit ça que tu craches
tu devais te mets ton mari lou mêmes
plats manea crash ou beth pas au début
trois fois par jour 6 passes et jeter
train à quatre mois par an et je tombais
quatre jours à l'utilité que ça m'arrive
est vraiment souvent depuis que j'ai les
enfants - parce que ça me force à a
quand même être plus équilibré délai à
trois morts faire des lego comme sujets
tantôt pendant trois heures ses stars
alors tout va balance le tout vraiment
plus le mais c'est 7 g
j'essaie de d'équilibré ma vie du mieux
que je peux avec les infections je
crache pas mais mais je pense que si
j'avais pu je continuerai de cracher des
fois des fois tu sais tout feu tout va
tellement vite et les projets se
chevauchent pis juste en mode
j'imagine en mode survie le café russe
continue et puis moi ça m'est arrivé
dernièrement d'arriver chez opi faire
juste chu brûlé complet pis même pas ça
fait trois jours je suis pas allé
m'entraîner j'ai comme j'ai pas le temps
juge us complètement vidé puis on dirait
que j'avais envie de dormir pendant six
mois
hal gill il est ce que c'est que tu
aurais envie de dormir dans ce mot ce
serait très envie d'un vrai contactez
moi des fois là je me rends compte que
j'ai épuisé parce que j'ai pas eu de
vrais contacts le contact dont je
parlais tantôt avec ma fille tu que
j'essaie de garder quand j'étais épuisée
souvent y auriez avec le fait que j'ai
pu rencontrer mon job ça fait longtemps
on sait pas on sait pas vraiment
rencontré ou ou même une amie j'ai la
chance d'avoir des liens d'amitié
vraiment fort ou maman et route est
souvent stockés sadrin de l'énergie
quand tu es juste en surface vraiment
puis c'est important à entretenir ce tu
es vraiment on se dit tout le temps que
ça va bien mais des fois ça va papillon
degrés c'est le délire t systems en
réponse automatique
ça va oui toi ouais on est tout le temps
ça je le dis à nous mêmes aussi ça se
pose des questions sur l importance de
questionner la tolar super bien parce
que pèche dans une vraiment bonne passe
ouais ça a été trois années difficiles
mais l'ol et ça remonte la pompe suis
content est ce que est ce que danser
dans ces années là tohu parents n'est
plus membre comme d'ailleurs les ce que
tu penses que ta vie personnelle avait
trop gros impact sur trop fort oui
vraiment ce que vous avez remarqué dans
le temps et marquer dans le succès de
l'entreprise que vous êtes séparés ce
qui a eu un impact direct
enfin pour peu près pendant ta première
question j'étais convaincu que que ça
s'effondre et nuire ou salle avoir un
impact parce qu'ils ont été un duo puis
ça fait dans ma tête et comme sid avance
je le savais j'agissais comme si la
fuite en connaissance de cause ouais je
m'étais trop par jour ça vaut si la
batterie qui est étrangement on connaît
une croissance à chaque année depuis je
touche du bois mais j'ai l'impression
que on a bien fait nos affaires dans le
sens où ou la mort ça vous web et wii
puis la marque si ça reste c'était mes
recettes et mon projet d'amour puis
troupes
alex a beaucoup aidés de voter
photographique sa meilleure forme et un
autre de grave
on a bien fait mon truc je pense que
l'intention dont je parlais tantôt était
tellement bon à la base qui elle est
restée la main fait les gens le stand by
en même temps sulser des recettes c'est
un domaine qui se démode pas puis je
pense qu'un appartement du gang le coeur
d'une personne ben a beau revenir parce
qu'à tout les jours aslef les e-bonds
cache également aujourd'hui c'est une
petite unité n'avantage kg et et les
gens pensent à nous à tous les jours
parce que trois fois par jour dans le
fait que heureusement pour l'instant n'y
a pas eu d'impact négatif aux contrats
tels que la croissance aurait juste été
plus accéléré son intérêt cet ensemble
finalement je m'en fous ok c'est pas
seulement je vis bien chanceuse dans vie
je vous êtes encore d'une certaine façon
un duo d'attaquants et pikine à la
business mais il est impliqué dans le
sens où heath et juments des conseils
sur certains trucs mais non il fait
grincer a fondu kg tout racheter ces
parts et ccc fait le saut qui est limité
il est impliqué dans la vie bien plus
haut niveau des filles c'est le sait
c'est un papa papa puis
ils voient ça va être comme ça toute la
vie fait keselowski et s'impliquer très
court oui alors super bien on te
souhaite souhaite de continuer à être
bien oui puis de continuer dans tous tes
projets puis vraiment la télé non vous
écris des buts
[Rires]